tennis la parole est à madame laurence
arribagé pour le groupe l'est
républicain présidente monsieur le
premier ministre
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi atteint
les chiffres records la croissance est
quasi nulle le monde agricole souffre la
crise des migrants est majeur et nos
concitoyens et nos entreprises sont
assommés d' imposer de taxes or cet été
en vue des élections régionales de
décembre prochain
vous avez fait en catimini une annonce
pour le moins surprenante
y compris d'ailleurs pour votre propre
camp celle de créer une nouvelle
fonction de président délégué de région
cette idée de projet de loi dont nous
avons tous appris l'existence par la
presse est totalement contraire à
l'esprit même de la décentralisation
sachant que boone abri à aucun moment la
question des ressources
vous devez savoir mes chers collègues
que cette dernière invention est issu
des tractations partiez les petits
arrangements entre amis en région
midi-pyrénées languedoc-roussillon
une fois le soutien les radicaux de
gauche assuré vous avez voulu monsieur
le premier ministre
contenter les ténors de votre parti que
sont madame delga et monsieur alary
c'est purement et simplement consternant
vous qui prenez un état exemplaire et la
réduction des dépenses publiques
vous multipliez aujourd'hui les postes
inutiles aux frais du contribuable à des
fins que réprouve l'éthique républicaine
mobilisée le parlement sur cette mesure
exclusivement électoraliste est
parfaitement contraire à l'intérêt
collectif et au mandat que nous ont
confié les françaises et les français en
midi pyrénées languedoc roussillon
cette loi fait pour un seul homme la loi
alary risque de finir en véritable foire
à l'exécutif alors voici ma question
monsieur le premier ministre
comment pouvez vous prenez l'efficacité
de l'action publique et favorise dans en
même temps l'organisation programmée du
désordre dans de jeunes région fusionner
je vous remercie de bien vouloir
renoncer
merci madame la députée la parole est à
monsieur le secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations avec le monde
merci mal après madame la présidente
madame et messieurs les députés
madame la députée laurence arrivages
merci de votre question qui va me
permettre je l'espère en tout cas
d'aborder cette question tout simplement
avec réalité effectivement dans le débat
sur les régions là l'idée de doter nos
futurs région d'un président-délégué
avait été évoquée mais en y regardant de
plus près nous nous sommes aperçus que
le droit actuel permettait cette
possibilité est d'ailleurs le monsieur
le député sauvadet dans le cadre du
conseil départemental de la côte d'or
avait mis en application cette
proposition il avait institué un
président délégué qui était
intermédiaire en deux présidents de
l'exécutif local et le premier vice
président alors effectivement la
législation actuelle madame la députée
permet éventuellement de recourir à cela
cela peut avoir un intérêt notamment
dans la fusion de grande région en
permettant une meilleure intégration
directoire bien sûr parce que vous
connaissez parfaitement le règlement des
collectivités locales
vous savez qu'en aucune façon ceci peut
entraîner une dépense supplémentaire
dans le fonctionnement des exécutifs
alors madame la députée avec la réforme
territoriale mettons en place une
nouvelle france des territoires avec
grande région qui permettent et nous
sommes là pour faciliter effectivement
là le rapprochement de l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales et
territoires et la proposition que vous
avez évoqué peut y participer